give from IBM the talk uh that you've
already heard a lot about the sort of
Correspondence between Fidelity and
cross entropy
okay thanks Bill and all the other
organizers for putting together this
great Workshop uh and for inviting me
and yeah I'm going to be talking about a
phase transition in this linear cross
interview Benchmark and with a joint
work with Braden where Dominique Kang
lighter pradeep nirola Bill fesselman
Alex
um okay let's begin
so one thing I really like about Quantum
Computing today is that we have so many
different architectures
um and I think it's also fair to say
that we don't yet know how Quantum
Computing architecture of like say 30
years from now is going to look like
and these architectures are all very
diverse and different
um and I think that's a really exciting
time for Quantum computing
um but there's also a problem which is
that we cannot
the fact that these architectures are so
different from one another makes it hard
to compare them to each other
[Music]
um
and yeah we we kind of sometimes lose a
handle of uh what's really going on
and uh with these architectures uh we
have seen for the first time some
evidence of economy advantage over
classical computation through the
sampling based experiments although as
Scott mentioned um that evidence is
probably hanging by a thin thread
uh and one thing that's making
understanding what's going on in this
experiments really hard is the fact that
we have noise and
um we don't really know how things
behave when we put a lot of them
together
um
so that brings us to this idea of
benchmarking
I should know that when we consider
these random circuit sampling
experiments we have moved to a setting
that's sort of native to the experiment
and because of this we have gone away
from the setting of decision problems
um and promising NP where we can
efficiently verify
so I'm going to distinguish uh verifying
a computation from benchmarking and
experiment
um and the reason is as follows imagine
that you're an experimentalist
um now I admit that sometimes it might
seem the case uh that your com and that
your experiment is behaving
adversarially against you uh but that's
really far away from
um what really happens in nature at
least that's what we believe
um
so for example yeah when we build an
experiment uh we have a high prior
against outlandish things such as there
being like a Gremlin sitting inside a
dilution refrigerator uh manipulating
you
uh
so uh we loosen our goal so our goal is
not really to convince a skeptic that's
something Quantum is really going on
inside here
um but rather build our own trust and
confidence in the quantum computers
components working well together
um and first it's like one metric
that is the Fidelity which is a notion
of how close the state that you produce
in an experiment is to some desired
Target state
um and I should know that when we are
talking about a quantity such as
Fidelity we are inherently assuming that
there is some underlying Quantum state
that we are producing and in this sense
we are already moving away from the
notion of
um some adversarial verification
um okay
so one problem with the Fidelity is that
it can take exponentially many examples
in the number of qubits to properly
Witness
in fact there are some sample lower
bounds
and
so an alternator that was proposed is
what we've seen today the linear cross
entropy Benchmark and it was proposed in
these two papers
um
and I'll Flash the definition again
so
this is the linear cross individ
Benchmark which I'll just denote the xcb
or Chi sometimes
um and here p is the ideal probability
of seeing an outcome X
whereas Q is what the experiment is
really sampling from
and we have this normalization
and yeah
So when you say exponential many samples
to witness what exactly do you mean
because I thought if I did Shadow
Fidelity estimation that's exactly
Italian
I believe there were lower bonds due to
Henry Ewing but maybe that's it
that's probably a different setting
thanks
so yeah
for ideal Quantum circuits this is close
to one with high probability
whereas when we are sampling from the
uniform distribution here Q then we'll
get a score of zero
and
yeah one nice thing about the linear
cross between Benchmark is that you can
sample efficiently
um
compute it so yeah here you just replace
Q with
um the samples that you see in the
experiment and that produces this
estimator
um yeah
but I should note that yeah as Dominic
mentioned in the previous talk that the
sister uh computationally inefficient uh
to compute so we still need to compute
the ideal probabilities of these bit
strings
okay so that's the xcb and there are
some nice things that have been claimed
about it so let's see
one claim is that if you have some noisy
random circuit sampling experiment
um where your gate set is somewhat
scrambling enough then xcb is the same
as the Fidelity
um
also uh it's believed that spoofing the
xcb is at least as hard as doing even
slightly better than random guessing
uh
although this was kind of disproven for
like certain settings of shallow depth
um
yeah and that that's what uh
these Works did
and
in these papers
um there was a justification given for
why the xcb is a good Fidelity proxy and
this works in something I call the low
noise limit which I'll get into soon
so the main question we want to
um ask in this talk is when is this uh
lean across databa Benchmark a good
proxy for the Fidelity
yeah here's an outline of the talk so
I'll first talk about the white noise
model which again was brought up before
and how it justifies the xcb
and I'll give a quick preview of like
the main results before I jump into like
the techniques
okay any questions so far
right let's get into this
so our setting is as follows we have uh
so this figures from dull cell at all we
have a random circuit where let's say we
have NQ edits here and the circuit has
depth d
and
we have locally random Gates applied
between units
and let's say at the end before we
measure we produce a noisy output State
row
now the White Noise approximation is
just the same as Global deeper Rising
noise it says that this noisy output
State before you measure is this linear
combination of the ideal Quantum State
and a mixture of the completely uniform
distribution
and
so if this approximation holds then the
xcb can be a good Fidelity proxy
and um so delzel at all studied when is
this a good approximation so in
particular
let's say they considered q-dips with
local Dimension Cube
and they considered these noise channels
to be that of single cuded unital noise
and the noise strength is measured
through either the infernal infidelity
are which will sometimes rescale by
Epsilon
you know by this Factor yeah so just
think of R and Epsilon kind of
interchangeably it's it's just
proportional to the night strength
and all these Works rely on
um
statistical mechanical model
um so it's a mapping from random
circuits to some model in statmec which
you can then study moments of
okay and
I'll mention some um prior works so as I
mentioned uh Del cell at all really
studied this quantity first
and what they were able to show was that
if the noise strength is
uh it's you know order one or n log n so
this is what I call the low noise limit
earlier
um then the White Noise approximation
works well for
um say quantities like second moments of
your output probability distribution
then you have a question
and uh yeah they
had some evidence that this couldn't be
improved to anything that that's like
some 0.3 over it and this this constant
is not telling point
they also showed that in this regime
which I'm calling the low noise regime
the Fidelity the cross interview
Benchmark and the distance to the
uniform distribution
um they all scale as exponential in the
noise strength times the circuit size
which goes as ND
um
meanwhile at higher noise rates let's
say the noise strength are for every
channel is a constant
this work also showed that the cross
Benchmark breaks down
in a sense that it doesn't reflect the
Fidelity anymore
and also our work
um with some others shows that in this
regime of large noise
the Toleration distance to the uniform
distribution
is lower bounded by a quantity that's
that goes like exponential in the my
strength times the depth
so this is
uh
they they these two do match when the
noise strength goes as 1 over n
but
um yeah so this means that we uh this
kind of scaling cannot go on forever as
you increase the noise
and what this essentially means is that
something qualitatively very different
is happening in the regime of low noise
and high noise
and that's what we seek to study in this
work
okay so our main claim in this work is
that there is some constant
that depends on the architecture and
gets it or whatever
such that if the noise strength Epsilon
is below C over the number of qubit
cudits
then the xcb is a good estimator for the
Fidelity
and if you're above this sort of noise
threshold then the correspondence
between xcb and Fidelity immediately
breaks down
and uh
the claim is that this happens as a
phase transition
um and as I said earlier this the
location of this depends on the geometry
of the circuit and what your gate set is
and yeah I'm stating this as like a
claim and not a theorem or something
because we rely on some numerical
evidence but we we trust this numerical
evidence
this is for any noise that's not uh
leakage
so in third sought to also work for
non-united noise
the same physics happening
um so the upshot is that as an
experimentalist one should really read
the warning sign on before using the
cross interview Benchmark as a benchmark
okay uh now I'll get into the techniques
and talk about this statmac model
so we really start off with the oldest
trick in the book
um
so we we want to get expressions of the
form Roman times row two and we instead
work with tensor products so when tensor
row two
uh I illustrate this with the Fidelity
here so in the case where we have where
the noiseless circuit is pure
um the Fidelity is simply given by this
expression
so it's the trace of these of the tube
to copy States
and I can write that as a swap times
these two copies here
and when when I take the expectation
value over a random circuit ensembles
um I can move the expectation into the
trace and I I I'm
I have this object remaining
um
so it all boils down to how this two
copy average State evolves in the
circuit
um
and we assume that in our circuit
architecture uh there's a layer of
single cubic cudit R random gates after
every game
okay so uh what this does is essentially
we end up taking expectation values over
states of this form
and
and yeah if you've seen this before uh
what this does is that you're
effectively projecting down to the
permutation symmetric Subspace which is
spanned by say the identity operator and
this s is the swap operator between the
two copies
and I've denoted by them by uh like I've
just normalized them by Q square and Q
respectively because I just want to work
with Trace one objects
and this is the formula that governs how
um
how these
how the average works
okay so it just suffices to keep track
of the average state
and now let me illustrate what happens
for the xcb
so we again go back to what the
definition of the Cross entropy
Benchmark was
uh it's this expectation
and
and yeah I can I can just rewrite it as
this
so I have a swap again and I notice that
I I have two copies of the state with
noise applied in one of the copies
so again it suffices to look at how this
object is evolving in a circuit
and this brings us to the update rules
of this statement model
so if I start off with any product state
then the higher average over the single
qubit States
um
just produces this linear combination of
the identity and the swap
and
after this what happens is that I can
now just think about my Dynamics as some
classical random work occurring over
these with strings there represent the
average operator
so in fact the
average to copy state that I mentioned
earlier is now just some it's a
distribution over say bit strings
and when we apply a two qubit unitary
we have the following
update rule for the stat back model
um
so the identity
s is the swap operator between one copy
and another copy that we had
mentioning here of the original state
yeah
so let's say we had right here I'm
assuming that PSI was a product State on
every qubit and we are just averaging
over like one layer of our random Gates
on that
okay so the right hand side is
independent it's independent yeah
yeah so under these update rules what
happens is that
um a state that was identity identity
which I denote as 0 0 here uh still gets
mapped to a zero zero
whereas if I had uh
sir if I had swap swap in like occurring
as some term in the combination then
that is also preserved so one one gets
mapped to a one one
this is the more interesting update rule
so if I have a 0 and a one
or one and a zero they get mapped to a
combination of zero zero and one one
okay
um
so I'll describe what's going on in the
physics of this model so under
application of unitaries we have these
update rules that I just mentioned
and one can easily observe that
the bit strings that are all zeros and
all ones are fixed points of the model
so if I have all zeros then I'll remain
all zeros that's what I mean by fixed
point
and
um
this means that there's like a unique
fixed Point State at really
asymptotically large depth uh which is
given by the following combination of uh
the all zero string in the all one
string
um
and this expression is the same as if
you took a higher random State and did
this two copy average
okay in the presence of noise uh the
physics of this model changes
and
yeah let's say we have again noise
strength R measured in terms of the
infidelity
um
what noise does is it keeps the identity
the same
whereas a swap operator uh decays to the
identity with some probability that's
proportional to the infidelity
okay
so in terms of
the split string notation a zero is
still a zero there is a 1D case to a
zero with some probability here
foreign
this state which was the all one state
is no longer a fixed point
so we only have one unique fixed point
now which is all zero state
and
yeah that leads to a decay in both the
Fidelity and the xcb
so in particular Let's uh
let's denote by X like the magnitude of
X the Hamming weight of a bit string X
so it's really counting how many swaps
are there in this presentation
now the Fidelity it turns out is given
by the following so you look at the
probability distribution over these bit
strings that I mentioned earlier
and you weight them by Q to the twice
the Hemingway
and then yeah you have this Q to the
minus n Factor
so the xcb is also an another observable
that it depends on this probability
distribution
and it's morally very similar looking we
are still looking at Hemingway except we
are just raising it to Q to the X
instead of Q to that 2 magnitude of s
and one can see that uh
under these unitary update rules the
Fidelity is conserved under all these
updates
and the xcb tends to evolve to one
and yeah as I mentioned earlier in the
presence of noise if yeah so the final
state is Again by this
so that would mean that the final
Fidelity is like Q to the minus n
um and the final xcb is zero
okay so that was a brief description of
what the physics of this model is
and um I'll now talk about some
numerical results
and so what we did was simulate this
static model for and I'm confused
um about the the mapping is between
um some
average over the random circuits
what exactly what's the what's the exact
statement
um
so these are the exact same it's like we
take an expectation Over The Ensemble so
under the same map thing you can you can
map the expected stability as well as
the expected question would be better
but what else
um is it we can do uh there are two copy
of examples so for example we can when
we write the Purity uh we'll have to put
the noise in both copies
[Music]
um
that would also evolve under similar
rules but yeah we just uh
yeah we now put noise in voice
is there a general Claim about
like what kind of quantities can you
match that you can know you can map any
expectation over any quantity any second
moment
and second moment point
but and can you extend it to three
copies or something like that or in
principle yes although the update rules
I think yeah
yeah so we simulated this static model
for a reasonably large system sizes
and they were extremely precise well I
should mention that I wasn't the one who
did these numerical simulations it was
bred in
and the way it was done was through like
a tensor Network representation of the
classical public distribution
and uh I would I would like to delineate
what's rigorous and what's not so the
expectation
value of fidelity and xcb uh
that can be written exactly as some
observable of this stat back model and
then we have done numerical simulations
of that static model which which could
perhaps be viewed as some heuristics
so one more thing we exploit is Hamming
symmetry so in particular when we
consider uh an all to all architecture
meaning that we have no spatial locality
constraints and after so in each layer
we apply just a random gate between any
two qubits
um what happens is that when we average
over all possible pairings of qubit
qubits and the
Gates themselves
then the upgrade rules depend only on
the Hemingway
so in particular we are just left with
uh
a rule like this
all right this was a two goes to two
um yeah and the noise update rule is
also similarly having symmetric
so uh the upshot of this is that now a
random walk occurs only in a space of uh
say n plus one Dimensions instead of 2
to the n and this means we can access
really large n
so yeah let me show you some numerical
results for the Fidelity so it starts at
one and decays very quickly as
well you said tensor networks yeah yeah
it can learn that um like we could have
just done like a Markov simulation and
that's what I was doing uh you know I'm
a very happy way but because the
Fidelity observable uh
you know it depends exponentially on the
Hemingway
uh it answered there are there are like
very few instances that contribute but I
like a really large factor and then you
know you always tend to under sample so
if you want like a really precise handle
of what the Fidelity is yeah it turns
out that yeah these distributions can
also be well approximated by low
abundance
okay
the center number is just like the state
like the vector of probabilities for
each Hemingway or
so what is it maybe going out this
question like why is better than just
keeping a list of all the way
um so a list of all the entries where
yeah they could take memory and
exponentially
like n plus one
oh okay yeah
yeah okay we also we also go like I
don't see once you're having
I mean there is no natural like warranty
or whatever structure
I mean before you do that mapping SEO
use Tesla networks right
um
yeah no so for the all to all we don't
really need attention networks but we
also did it in one day and without doing
the Hamming okay
yeah
yeah so this Fidelity decays uh really
fast at first uh as like one minus
Epsilon to ND so I'm looking at Fidelity
versus a rescale notion of uh depth
um so it turns out that uh
yeah different noise strengths all
collapse on to this same curve
um
and then in the Decay until you hit this
floor of Q to the minus M which is
increased the lowest you can go
uh in fact there's still some deviation
away from Q to the minus n
but that's not so visible here
um
yeah in fact in goes as Q to the minus n
plus something that still uh
exponentially separated away from Q to
the minus n
okay let's look at xcb now
um so it turns out that the xcb behaves
as follows when you have low noise
strings uh the xcb decays pretty similar
to the Fidelity so this black dashed
line is uh how the Fidelity decays
um but beyond a certain noise strength
uh in the snow correspondence anymore
between the Fidelity and the xcb
uh in fact
there's probably a stronger claim which
is that the Decay rate of the xcb
is now not reflective at all of any
inherent noise strength in your system
um
so let's let's look at this asymptotic
Decay rate of the xcb
which is this essentially this the slope
of this line
and
that shows this following feature
again at low noise strengths from like
0.45 to up to 0.9
um the Decay rate of the xcb depends on
the line strength
but after a certain noise strength all
these deeper shades of blue they all
converge to you know this this line
so the xcb DK rate is a function of
noise for a small noise but is noise
independent after that
so okay we asked whether there's a
transition here
and
it turns out that the
slope which governs the Decay rate of
the xav uh looks like this
um
we think there's a sharp crossing here
at something like 0.92
and because we have done this having
symmetry uh
you know we have gone to this Heming
symmetric Subspace
we can actually compute the eigenvalues
of
um the transfer Matrix that
[Music]
was entropy in the Fidelity or the same
yes or any amount of noise so
how come you don't have any dependence
on the distance from the white noise
uh so in the I mean if if you're if your
noise is is White Noise then the the
transition then there is no separation
between the Fidelity yeah so what's
really happening is that
White Noise approximation itself is
but you didn't
I mean you cannot break down unless you
say that your noise is far from the
white noise
right or or oh you're saying you're
saying uh you're assuming local noise
and the Very approximation of the White
Noise yes breaks down regardless of the
nature of the noise right
local language
yeah even if you have local decorations
yeah previously we only had guarantees
that uh the White Tile approximation
works when it when the noise tank
there's like one over n log n
um
okay and we are no longer in language
yeah so we can also confirm this picture
using uh the fact that we had this
Heming symmetric Subspace
and
we can actually compute the eigenvalues
of I guess the transfer Matrix that
governs the update rules of the project
distribution
and
we find that the Decay rate of the xcb
is well characterized by what the
leading non-zero eigenvalue here is so
for small noise rates the the xcb
decorate is given by given by this curve
here until it crosses here and
that remains constant
and
um
yeah so so this leads to an estimate for
where the transition should be
which is Epsilon n something like log of
Phi over 2.
and yeah
so there was this recent paper by Marvin
atoll who claimed that this transition
in xcb also corresponds to a transition
in whether the xcb is poofable or not
uh in fact they also saw the XUV
transition I mentioned earlier
experimentally
and yeah like
I just want to start like
um think a lot about whether there's any
hope of proving such a transition in
complexity
and
like we can look at both the easy side
and the hard side
so on the easy side uh we would like to
show that if the noise strength is
larger than some constant or n then this
go into one algorithm that was recently
analyzed better in in this paper
we would like to show that that works
but the problem is that it has a runtime
that scales exponential in one over the
noise strength and in the regime that we
are working with where of low noise this
would have a not so good scaling
on the hardness side
um we would like to show that at a
sufficiently small noise strings using
the fact that there is a white noise
approximation to the primary
distribution
um yeah we can justify harness or
sampling
phase transition happens at C over n and
even further for the spoof ability I
mean oh for the spoofability yeah
it depends on whether there is a phase
transition in the first place right sure
but you said you said you said that that
someone ever argued that they're
empirically there seems to be one
yeah
that's right so so so what are they
seeing in their data are they seeing
like a sharp as you adjust the uh hour
the like
your friend that at some value of C it
jumps or is it just that it's smoothly
you know as you adjust see it
is yeah
um I do recall some thoughts where they
look like yeah there are some
there's some crossover and the points at
which radius curves intersect uh seems
to be independent of system size but
yeah I think
uh there are smallish numbers yeah see
maybe maybe I really
on the paper
uh yeah so that brings me to the end
um so we have seen so this is a study of
when the xcb is informative and when it
isn't
um and this is hopefully a way of
comparing different experiments
and yeah so we focused on this low noise
regime in this talk
um
can you get anything at constant noise
one issue is that at constant noise
the Fidelity decays very fast to the
minimal value at so at constant depth
you're already very close to ql minus n
and actually this is also why the
Fidelity doesn't really witness the
transition
Because by the time the transition is
set has occurred the Fidelity is also
already very close to it's minimal
and there's some things I didn't tell
you about which is that yeah we have a
prediction for where this transition
occurs
um
and that that comes from this analysis
of how the eigenvalues of the transfer
Matrix look like
um
it turns out that the entangling power
of the gate set is uh very important
notion
so we'd like to improve uh this
prediction to other circuit
architectures like say d dimensional
lattices
and yeah as I mentioned earlier for
non-unitial noise in the statmac model
is model is the same and like the same
physics goes through
for for these Fidelity and xcb
observables which are just
observables where you have noise in one
copy of the state
but if you are looking at other
quantities like the noisy Collision
probability which is related to purity
um
then the physics is different
and yeah there's some work on in this
direction of non-unitable Noise by
performance
yeah and
are there other ways of bringing these
calculations uh closer to what is really
uh being done in experiments uh one one
other feature that experiments have is
like yeah they don't really consider
High random single cuded Gates but
instead gets chosen from some discrete
set so yeah that that might or might not
change some of the things we see here
yeah that's all thank you
[Applause]
you started out by talking about
and it seems to me that if I was an
experimentalist and I wouldn't feel it
I would do something like if I have run
it for a certain distance then I would
invert the circuit and see what we get
all zeros again and that would be a very
good measure of the Fidelity of my
Hardware or I could run the Clifford
circuits I mean there are so many things
you could do that could check the
Fidelity which are not of this nature
and then you could ask whether you see
this cross um entropy is only good when
the output distribution is very flat
otherwise you know if you're interested
in that so then
then say when I'm running it in a manner
that produces a plot distribution is it
matching what I'm getting when I run
forward and back it seems that there's
so many ways that experimentalists would
check this without mentioning anything
of the kind of things that are being
discussed by
computer scientists or anyone else it
would just measure it you know my goal
am I missing something about two things
calibration address
so if you're over rotating consistently
then yeah once you
another is the fact that we have these
really nice and a lot systems where we
don't really have as much
controllability as you know the
experiments you mentioned so I feel
there the exhibit can be a good way of
comparing different architectures with
one another
okay
yeah it has to do away uh the upgrade
rules of the State Bank module uh so
when you are only applying noise to one
copy
what happens is that after after you do
this High random averaging
um
yeah the identity is still mapped to
another
even though the noise is
and but once you have non-intentional
noise in both copies this is no longer
the case so the thing is
this is
cheating fast now haven't you kind of
killed the xcp because if you really
believe this then when you get to
sufficiently many qubits you're always
we will describe this as a transition
around additional scaling methods are
you actually able to scale up
yeah so uh
one thing is that you know you can be
interested in the XUV in
even if you're totally uninterested in
complexity right because you just want
to know how your experiment is going
when you are putting in more and more
yeah and and if you have sufficiently
low noise uh hopefully you know
this can give away of predicting where
the transition should occur so if you
know you are likely below that uh
threshold then you can trust it and
breaks again
the second question is it still one over
n in the old to all case because that's
for the locals right so I would think
it's a faster power
it's the it's the same phone as well
wait you when you say faster you mean
like even lower even lower no yeah one
over n is good enough
because I think uh one way to look at it
is that in each layer we are still
applying so in this particular model we
are still applying the theater of n
training gates in each layer because we
are randomly pairing that qubits and so
it is scrambling fast enough
come on what's the physical meaning
what kind of answer right
now
well
I mean something is happening there and
concentricity Benchmark is a quantity
that is
very computer sciencey to take every
word
uh
there's something physical going on
there what is what is going on there why
why is there a face transition there
yeah I don't know it's a very
interesting question I think perhaps I
would be a point where like it's a
somewhat unnatural emotion uh in the
sense that
physics don't really like to
look at noise like 10
scaling yeah
there's something happening here no but
but even even these emerging noise for
example there is
[Music]
such a weak preservation you have to do
to go from autism accounts but it's the
same kind of transition right it's a
large random graph you can think of it
so they are common
I think it's also a very specific
transition to the Cross entropy
Benchmark right
we
I mean yeah if you look at generic two
copy quantities
how
how the Fidelity and oh sorry how the
exhibit really close to
these The Observers that are of Interest
here
I don't know it seems to be like it
cannot be very isolated just to The
Taste or something
yeah I I think it's a very interesting
condition
and yeah this is our first studying
oh no I have a question so uh
what we really care about is probably
somewhere in between whatever
you know and I think
like by us taking a poll it seems like
most people believe that fertility is
along the same thing should hold but can
you tell us any sort of better reason
about why why we why would we believe
that and it's just sort of hard to
calculate or do you think it's
interesting to look into that or not or
do you know
yes if you imagine a
yeah
yeah most
yeah I put this technique model there is
doing is really obtaining
say I guess these things that are like
sort of saying uh baby
can affect the physics of it uh but yeah
I think yeah we believe that for next
week
a similar transition so the counseling
would change yeah
okay should we take a break
[Applause]
thank you